(intense music)
(lively music)
- Welcome to another
episode of In the Arena.
I'm Jonathan Stein.
Our guest today is Andrea Headley.
A UC Presidential Post
Doctoral Fellow for 2018,
here, at the Goldman
School of Public Policy
and, an incoming professor
at the policy school
at the Ohio State University.
Her research focuses on
criminal justice, and,
specifically, their
relationship between police
and, the communities they serve.
Andrea, welcome.
- Thank you.
- Thank you for being here.
- Thanks for having me.
- One of the themes of
In the Arena has been
that the scholars and the
researchers and the advocates
that we talk to, often, have
a, deeply, personal connection
with the work that they do,
or, the research they're investigating.
They have something inside of them,
that motivates them to do
the work that they're doing.
Do you feel like that's
true for you, as well?
- Yeah, so, I, actually,
definitely, feel that that is true.
I've always been interested,
just, generally, speaking,
in doing work that made a difference
for solving public problems.
But, the criminal justice
aspect of my research,
in particular, was rooted
in me from a very young age.
I thought I was going to be an attorney,
so, I'd be like you, right.
And, I thought, particularly, I was going
to be a public defender.
And, I wanted to be a public defender
because of my family and friends
that I've seen that had involvement
with the criminal justice system,
and, the experiences
that they shared with me,
or, their experiences that I witnessed.
And, I thought that I can,
you know, make a difference.
It was when I went to undergraduate
that I got involved in research
and, I realized that research
can be another avenue
to affect change, not
just becoming an attorney
or, a lawyer, and, so, that,
really, propelled my research trajectory.
And, in terms of policing, in particular,
when I started my doctoral program, I
actually, though that I was
going to research incarceration
or, juvenile detention centers,
but, a year after I started my program,
it is when Ferguson happened, so, in 2014,
and, it, really, put a lot
of spotlight on the tensions
between police and communities.
And, it also, showed the need for research
to try and help to solve
some of the problems
that we we're seeing in the community.
- So, let's dig into your research,
and, let's start with a topic
that Ferguson surfaces, right?
You've studied cities
that have high levels
and, low levels of police
community conflict.
What are some of the
factors that determine
whether a city and a police department
have high levels or low
levels of that conflict?
- Yeah, so, and, one part of my research
I was able to try and understand
what the community socioeconomic
characteristics were,
that were correlated with the high
or low police citizen conflict.
And, what I found was that communities
that had higher poverty,
higher unemployment,
higher violent crime,
and, higher female headed
housing levels, also had,
really, high levels of
police citizen conflict.
And, that those communities that
had low police citizen conflict were,
usually, associated with
higher median income,
higher median ages, higher
levels of owner occupied housing.
And, so, I think, the
community characteristics,
really, do make a difference in trying
to understand police citizen conflict.
But, I wouldn't go as far as to say
that it predicts, you know,
police citizen conflict.
- Right.
So, what are some of the characteristics
of police departments,
where there are low levels
of police community conflict?
- So, what my research found,
was that, in terms of
police citizen conflict,
when we're looking at things
like police use of force,
civilian complaints about police officers,
assaults against officers,
that there are certain factors
that are correlated, and, in particular,
my research has found that
the police departments
that had much high levels
of racial representation,
meaning that they had a
lot of people of color
on the police department, as it pertained
to the level of people of
color in the community,
and, police departments
that also were engaged
in community partnerships,
those departments
had much lower levels
of police use of force.
Also, what my research found,
was that police departments
that higher percentages of officers
that were dedicated to
community policing roles,
or, problem solving roles,
had much lower levels
of civilian complaints, as well.
So, in terms of what
police departments can do
I think that it points to one, the role
of community policing,
and, community partnerships
but, also, the role of
racial representation,
and, hiring people of color,
and, having a diverse police force.
- And, just for our
watchers who might not know,
can you define community policing,
and, what it means for
police officer to be
in a problem solving role,
as opposed to something else?
- Right, so, what it means for an officer
to be in a problem solving role, means
that that police officer, is,
specifically, dedicated
to engaging the community
and, positive enforcement activity,
I mean, positive
nonenforcement activities.
Meaning, that they're not
necessarily responding to call
for service, or an allegation
about criminal activities,
but, rather, they're going out
and, meeting with community stakeholders,
they're attending community events,
they're walking the beat, for instance,
and, building relationships,
and, that's what their
role is, primarily, for.
- You're research identifies solutions,
in addition, to identifying
these characteristics
of police departments
that have high levels
and low levels of community conflict.
You also identify solutions.
And, you have a number of
organizational solutionS.
Organizational reform,
also some other things,
that are more about the
individual police officer.
and, one thing, I found interesting,
is that your research calls
for increased soft skills,
for police officers.
And, soft skills are not something people,
traditionally, think of as
prerequisite for being a cop.
But, your research shows that,
actually, they can be,
critically, important.
- Right, so, that was,
actually, one of the findings
that surprised me a little bit,
when I was doing this research.
So, I went in to this, really, thinking
that the organization mattered,
and, so when I was doing
a lot of this research,
I was trying to, specifically, focus
on the organizational,
administrative, managerial factors
of police departments.
And, what I found was that yes,
the organization may matter,
but, also, it's the individual
that matters, as well, right,
the individual police officer.
And, that's, really, where the
soft skills, came in to play.
And, two soft skills, in particular,
that were important, were
the communication skills
of the officer, and then
an officer's character.
So, in regards to the communication skills
of an officer, I would hear officers,
often, say things like community relations
is communication, right.
It's about winning the community over,
one community member at a time,
or one incident, at a time.
And, I think that's really in alignment
with a lot of the procedural
justice literature,
that has come out, about how you engage
with civilians, how you
can talk civilians down,
how you can deescalate, et cetera.
And, then, in terms of character,
often what was brought up was the respect
that an officer has for the community,
whether or not they are empathetic,
they're caring, they're compassionate.
And, community members were often the ones
to talk about these things,
and, they would often suggest,
that the character that an officer has,
can be displayed in their actions,
and, that when there is
not respect, or, empathy
or, care and concern, that
the community loses trust,
in the police department, and,
that hinders police community relations.
- So, let's talk more about body cameras.
- Okay.
- Your research on body cameras,
have found a number of things.
One is, they often result
in better resolutions
of incidents, between police officers,
and, members of the public,
fewer incidents of violence,
for example, it doesn't result
in substantial de-policing,
- [Andrea] Right.
- But, also, it increases
officers' skepticism, over time.
And, over time, a number
of officers, some officers,
begin to not use or not
turn on their body camera.
So, it's a bit of a mixed bag there.
And, there are some reformers
who say it's band-aid
on a, much, larger problem.
So, in your view, body cameras,
legitimate reform, band-aid,
or, something else?
- Yeah, so, I actually,
think the body worn cameras,
are a tool, to help us to
get to a place, where we can
have relationships between
police and the community
that are built on, you know, transparency,
and, accountability and things like that.
I don't think that it
is the end all, be all,
or, the panacea to, really, solve some
of the underlying issues,
that have resulted or that
have been brought to light,
recently, with police
in minority communities.
But, I do think that it's a tool
that can be used to help the situation,
and, I think, right now,
it's too soon to say
whether or not body cameras, as a whole,
are having the intended impacts,
because a lot of the research
has produced mixed findings,
particularly, because of the variations
and, policy contexts in
which the body cameras
have been deployed.
So, different departments
are deploying cameras
and, have different types
of policies on cameras,
so, when you're trying
to compare the findings,
it's hard to have an conclusive evidence.
So, I wouldn't shut the
door on body cameras
just yet, but, I think that it's a tool
that has to be coupled with
other accountability mechanisms,
and, other reform mechanisms, as well.
- So, situating body
cameras in a larger context
of accountability mechanisms, right?
One, of the things that reformers
and, policy makers, hear
from law enforcement
and, police officers, is,
in the face of body cameras,
increased scrutiny, et cetera,
we're going to de-police.
Can you explain what de-policing is?
And, whether it,
actually, happens when you
have additional oversight
or accountability,
over police departments
and law enforcement?
- Yeah, so I think that's a great question
because that is, definitely, a narrative
that we've head a lot, and, that was one
of the things, that the police department
that I was working with,
actually, said a lot.
De-policing, also referred to
often as the Ferguson Effect,
is, essentially, a concept
that came about after Ferguson,
because of the rise in crime,
in particular, we saw rises
in homicide rates across
a variety of cities, in the United States.
And, so, the narrative, is that officers
are not, necessarily, doing their jobs as
effectively, or as proactively
as they once was, once were
because of the tensions
that have been present
between police and communities.
The assaults against
law enforcement officers
that have happened in places
like, Dallas, for instance.
And, so police officers,
are shrinking back due
to this anti-policing
sentiment, and, so crime rate
is going up, right, so,
that's the general idea behind
the notion of de-policing.
In regards to whether
or not this is a thing
or, if this is, really, happening,
I think that depends on what type
of indicators you are looking at.
And, when we're looking at qualitative
or perceptual accounts,
from officers, for instance,
there is real and legitimate
concerns about them
going above and beyond,
and, being very proactive
and, doing a lot of the
self-initiated activities
such as pedestrian or traffic stops.
However, they often do say,
that, you know they're
still responding to calls,
and, doing the things that
they have to do, but, not,
necessarily, going above and beyond.
And, they say that because
there is a low morale,
there's lack of motivation, there's lack
of enthusiasm to do
their job, there's fear
of punishment, et cetera.
- Because of all the scrutiny,
accountability mechanisms,
- Right, exactly, and, I bring that up
because I think it's important
to validate officers'
concerns and perceptions
because the psychological
literature does show
that the perceptions and
attitudes can impact behavior.
But, when you look at quantitative studies
or, quantitative indicators,
that try and see,
well, our police officers,
really, not doing their jobs, right?
There's some differences that we see.
So, for instance, in Baltimore,
after the Freddie Gray,
the death of Freddie Gray,
what we saw was that
police may have pulled back
on their proactive policing activities
and, there was a spike in homicides
that was, immediately,
following, you know,
the years after the Freddie Gray incident.
However, in places like
Milwaukee, after the beating
of people of color, in
particular, a black man,
what we saw there, was
that 911 calls dropped,
significantly, immediately
following those incidents.
And, when you're looking
at both of these incidents
as it pertains to de-policing, as a whole,
what this, really, points
to is that it may not,
necessarily, be all on
the police shrinking back
from their responsibilities or not,
necessarily, being as
proactive, but, it may also be
in terms of the community,
not calling the police, as much, right.
So, it's important to,
really, get at the mechanisms
by which this phenomenon, if occurring,
how it's occurring, why it's occurring,
when it's occurring, and, so forth.
- So, you've talked to
innumerable police officers,
body cameras won't work if
they're turning them off,
accountability mechanisms won't work
if they're choosing to withdraw
- Right.
- from the community
interactions they used to have.
As, the qualitative research suggests,
may be not the quantitative research,
how do you implement,
how can policy makers,
implement reforms, accountability
measures, oversight,
without encountering, the
sort of negative impacts
that we're talking about that,
actually, hurt the cause,
that hurt the cause of public safety?
- Right, yeah, so, I think that takes
a real collaborative effort
with police department
and community stakeholders.
I don't think that it can be
all on the police department,
to, you know, employ a body camera program
without getting community input, without
having a community oversight board
that's able to see what's happening,
internally, in the police department,
and, likewise, sometimes there's
civilian oversight boards
that are, completely, detached
from the police department
and, then they can't
get access to the type
of data that they need.
So, I think that there's, really, a need
for an effort that's collaborative,
that works together, not so
much that there's anything,
you know, funny going
on, but to the extent
that they can provide checks and balances
on each other, but, I also,
think that one of the things,
that we realized in the body camera study
that I conducted, was that officers,
being regularly, monitored
by their supervisors,
to ensure compliance was important,
and, as soon as officers were not being
regularly, monitored, to
see if they were complying
or what have you, that's
when compliance dropped
and, I think that alludes to the point
that there needs to be
someone that's watching
someone that's making
sure these activities are
actually, being conducted in
the way that they're intended
to be conducted, at least
until, it becomes normal,
and, everyday behavior.
- So, let's talk about
a different subject:
profiling by proxy.
So, profiling by proxy is when
the police are in a position
where they have to respond
to a call, made by a
community member where
the community member themselves,
are racially profiling.
And, so we've seen innumerable
examples of this in the news.
But, a young black man
is eating a sandwich
in a campus plaza and someone says,
why is that person on the campus?
Not realizing they're a graduate student,
and, calls the police to investigate.
That's a hypothetical I made up,
but, there's countless examples
of real life instances of this.
So, I think if someone is, let's say,
not aware of histories
of race and interactions
between communities of color and police,
they might say to themselves,
well there's an easy
solution, to profiling
by proxy, the police officer arrives,
realizes that this is nonsense,
they admonish the caller,
for wasting their time, and,
probably, being a little but racist,
and, go about their day.
I think that assumption
that that can be the easy,
quick, simple, harmless
solution to the situation
misunderstands the role
the police officers
and, police departments have played
in sort of enforcing racial codes
over the course of American history.
I'm wondering if you can
respond to the well-intended
community member who says to themselves,
why aren't the police in position to,
simply, diffuse the situation,
sniff out the racism,
and, resolve the situation,
positively, for everybody.
- Right, so, I think
you hit it on the head,
and, I think that that
response, really, ignores
the complex, and often
conflicted relationship
that has existed throughout time,
between disadvantaged communities,
people of color, and, law enforcement.
It misunderstands the history
that has over-policed
communities of color,
it misunderstands the issues
around police brutality
and, aggressive policing practices
that have been displayed
in various communities.
And, I think it also, misunderstands
the notions between assuming
that there's criminality
that's associated with
certain groups of people
certain races or ethnicities,
or, religious groups, or what have you.
I also think that that statement,
although well intended, one,
takes away the responsibility
of the person who's calling, and, I think
as civilians, we have a responsibility,
as well, to make sure that we're calling
about legitimate concerns
and legitimate behaviors,
and, are questioning ourselves.
And, it also assumes that the same biases
that are present in the caller,
are absent in the police officer,
and, it's not to say that that's not true,
but, we don't know that that's the case,
until after the situation
has already escalated.
Often times, what we've seen is that
it takes very small situations
to lead to very escalated situations.
And, it happens very quickly.
And, the last thing I'll say about this
is that it also ignores the fact
that there may be an inherent fear,
in the person the police was called on,
because of their prior
experiences with police officers
because what they've seen
on the tv or what have you,
and, how that fear may
then, impact their response
when the police officer shows up, so.
- Right, I think the first question
that a policy analyst, or
somebody with a policy brain
is going to ask, is
what's the intervention?
What is the policy solution
to policing by proxy
or uh profiling by proxy?
But, some of your research shows that it's
actually, not legislation that's going
to solve the problem,
it's something softer.
- Right, yeah, so, I think that
honestly, for this issue
of profiling by proxy,
there's always things that we can say
have policy implications, right?
But, I think, really, to get
at the root of the problem,
it would be forcing community members,
people who call the
police often, ourselves,
to ask the hard questions, right?
Ask yourself why are
you calling the police,
is there criminal activity being exhibited
that you're seeing, right?
Is there a threat or a danger?
Are you calling the police
because your own fears are also associated
with certain demographic
groups or certain behaviors
by certain demographic
groups that are not,
inherently, criminal,
but just don't fit well
with what you think should be displayed.
Asking yourself if the police come
is it going to make the situation better?
Asking yourself how would I feel if this
was a member of my family?
If the police coming an
appropriate response?
And, I think, if we can ask
ourselves these tough questions,
and, really, get to the root of it,
that can help, hopefully,
to eliminate some
of the problems that we're seeing.
I will say, though, that there is a role
that policy can play,
particularly, as it pertains
to the role of 911 dispatchers,
and, how information is received
from the callers, right, so, making sure
that there's appropriate
training and protocol
to ask probing questions,
when someone is calling the police,
to try and get at the root of the problem.
And, then how that information
is, then, transmitted to officers.
But, I know 911 dispatchers
is bag in itself,
and, there's a lot of
things that go in to that.
But, I do think that
there could be a role,
for policy to play, but,
I don't necessarily know
that the first role, at least.
- Right, so let's talk about
two big picture questions
here as we begin to wrap up.
The first is, some of
your research has found
that if you put body
cameras on police officers,
some portion of them are going to turn
those body cameras off.
Another has found that
when considering complaints
against police officers, the race
of the complainant makes a difference.
And, African Americans who complain
about police officers, are much more,
likely, to have their complaint dismissed,
than other complainants.
Also, you found that if you have more,
as we discussed earlier, if
you have more people of color
on the police force, it's
going to improve relationships
with communities of color.
Do you ever find yourself thinking
I'm using data to find things
that any community member in East Oakland
could've told me or anyone if
we had taken the time to ask,
I'm sure you do.
- Right.
- And, can you speak to the importance
of data and research, that
validates community narratives
when some of those community
narratives go ignored?
- Right, yeah, so, I,
actually, remember hearing
a scholar, giving a keynote
and the scholar said
essentially, that scholarship
is not about finding truth,
it's about providing evidence
to underscore truth, right.
And, it's this idea that scholarship
really, just confirms what
the community already knows,
or, seeks to at least to understand,
it doesn't always confirm.
So, scholarship seeks to understand
what the community may or
may not already know, right.
And, I think that quote,
really, resonates to this,
what you're talking about,
what you're asking about.
But, I think data is important
and, research is important for
a variety of reasons, right.
So, the first one, is that
it, really, like you said,
it validates community member experiences,
often times it can help
to inform decisions,
and, inform solutions.
It may shed light on the
magnitude of the issue,
so, maybe there's a couple
community experiences,
but, we don't know how
large this problem is.
Or, on the other end, maybe
this is just, you know,
a very unique problem for a
very specific group of people
or a specific street in the community.
And, it's not as widespread,
as maybe a narrative may say it is, right?
And, I think both of those are important
to be able to tease out, you know,
what's really going on, right.
What the mechanisms by
which, whatever problem
whatever phenomenon is being exhibited,
what are the mechanisms by
which it's, actually, you know,
occurring or happening to get
to some of the policy solutions.
And, some people love data,
some people love community narratives,
and, I think it's about
knowing what to use,
to which audience to try,
and, get whatever solution,
or, change, or, whatever
argument you're trying
to put forth, and, I think
that is, really, key.
- I always think about a story
I read about an individual,
who had cognitive and mental disabilities.
Who lived in a back of a
convenient store that was
he lived there, basically,
because of the grace
of the convenient store owner who knew
he was marginally housed,
and, needed a place to stay,
and, did some odd jobs
around the convenient store
in order to make a little bit of money.
And, he was sort of on
the margins, in many ways.
And, the police department,
in order to meet their
quotas were arresting him,
like 20, 30 times, every couple months,
just to get the numbers and
then they'd release him back,
and, they'd come and just
pick him up the next day.
And, it was always some new reason.
And, it was sort of a tragic story.
That individual isn't
going to build a narrative
in advocacy for himself,
and, for his community
that's going to change the
local police department
or, change policing on the whole.
And, frankly, other members
of that same community,
aren't going to disrupt their lives
in a way that is going
to like force reform
on the police department.
It's not something that
they should have to do.
But, those stories in combination
with, as you're saying, in
combination with research,
that maybe has purchase,
among policy makers,
among law makers, among
police chiefs, and so on.
Put all that together,
and, now all of a sudden,
you have maybe something that
it brings positive changes, so.
- Last question, the biggest question,
I think, in your field.
We've talked about what results
in positive police community relations,
what characteristics can result
in negative police community relations,
what is the ideal state?
What is it that through all the reform,
the legislation, the
scrutiny, and, the oversight,
what is it that we're trying to achieve
when it comes to policing
and the communities
that police serve?
- Yeah, so that's always
the million dollar question.
And, I think the ideal state
for police community relations
is one that's symbiotic, in nature, right?
It's based on mutuality,
and, mutual respect,
mutual trust, mutual cooperation.
And, it's one in which the
police and the community
are, really, working,
collaboratively, together, right.
And, it's this idea that the community,
essentially, right, are the
owners of government, right,
and, they're the ones
that are supposed to,
at least, be directing how they want
their community services to be delivered,
or what have you, policing
being one of those services.
And, in my opinion, and,
based on the research
that I've done, I think when
you're talking about police
and communities working
together, in particular,
there's three different types of ways
that police and communities
can work together.
And, the first way, is what we often see
which is police, maybe showing
up at community events,
maybe a certain designated officer who's
a community policing officer,
or, the public relations
officer, will show up,
and, participate in certain events,
and, be present in the community,
and, I think that's
great and that's needed.
I don't think that's, necessarily, enough.
The second thing is, what we've seen
is police, and, this is
I think, rarely seen,
but, it's still evident in some places,
where police departments
open up their doors
to the community to come in, right.
So, in Hartford, what they would do
was they would have a public CompStat,
which they would have a day
where the community members
could come in, and they could go over all
of their crime statistics,
they could go over
the different patrol activities
that they are doing to,
really, show the community
this is what we're doing,
this is why we're doing
it, this is where we are.
Likewise, when they had
a high profile incident,
they would would call
community leaders in,
and, debrief the community leaders,
immediately, after and say
you know, this is what happen,
our officers did this,
this is the video we have,
this is whatever, whatever, right?
And, so that's, really, different,
than just the police
showing up at events, right.
It's bringing the community members
in to the police department.
And, then, the last thing,
is where the police department
and the community identify
problems, together,
and, work to build solutions, right.
So, whether there is a certain community
a neighborhood within the community
or a certain group, or,
block within the community,
that's, really, causing problems,
or, maybe needs a little extra
attention, or what have you,
it's the police and, the
community coming up together,
to see what is the best approach for this,
how can we best deal with this,
and, listening to both sides,
rather than the police thinking,
you know, let's just over-police, and
aggressively, police this behavior,
or, rather than the
community trying to get
what they call street justice,
and, going to take things
in to their own hands.
- Thank you so much.
- Thank you.
- Andrea, I appreciate you being here.
Andrea Headley is
a 2018 UC Presidential
Postdoctoral Fellow,
and, is soon to be a assistant professor
at the Ohio State University.
Thanks for tuning in to, In the Arena.
(intense music)